alors voulu revoir une séquence mythique
dans le grand bluff de patrick sébastien
il s'était grimé en candidats sur le
plateau du millionnaire afin de piéger
philippe risoli moi c'est vraiment avec
le poème ou widi truculence nuance est
truculente me rappelle c'était énorme
c'est un de tes trois moments télé culte
regardez
[Musique]
on fait de repères vanish et reber
bonjour
soyez le bienvenu alors ça va très bien
bien très bien
bon je vous regarde tout à l'heure ça
qu'on s'est rencontrés deux secondes
avant l'émission oui je trouvais que
vous avez un peu le physique d'un savant
fou je suis un peu un original
ouais c'est un petit peu un original et
en est que je suis poète j'adore la
poésie bon je vous proposais d' sur tf1
vous les points de vue des deux parties
on a un petit papier avec moi j'ai je
peux ça me ferait plaisir dans leur
traque la pintade aux yeux violets
gloussant près du torrent qui bout de
kits autres cultures et pourquoi des
gens ne parlons de quel point ce sont
des néologismes ruraux petit truc eu le
dessus dû aller comme thunder
je sens que vous vous moquez savent non
pas du tout ok c'est pas très clair
qu'on ne manque jamais on s'amuse comme
si on se dit c'est pas très gentil
je veux que jamais dit moi on va aller
tourner la roue c'est l'émotion ça va
c'est pas en plus vous avez créé un
point pour vous à pour moi oui
alors oui mais non bas les masques de
bon coeur alors là ce qu'il est pour
vous alors vise au lit le joli je suis
l'ami du soleil mais mes yeux sont usées
aux lumières des studios et peut-être il
me faut guérir guérir guérir il le faut
car il parle il me faut virer un
ophtalmo oui car depuis qu'il est là son
regard dans le bien j'aurai dû
reconnaître le coup tu peux le dire
patrick sébastien aux gens qu'il est
prisonnier
c'est une chose qui ne coûtait rien
parce que les caméras étaient déjà sur
l'assaut donc c'était vraiment une idée
de génie sthers a fait un carton
d'audience mais le pays l'ont fait une
rediffusion genre deux ans après il a
fait 9 millions c'est waou
raphaël qu'a également choisie la télé
culte de jean yves lafesse alors
impossible de choisir un seul et balawi
aux comptes a fait une compil honte a
faim il voudra complice et l dernière
extract choisi ce sera sur le lot bien
évidemment c'est jean yves lafesse
regarde bonjour bonjour bonjour comment
allez vous faire [ __ ] vous allez
allez vous faire [ __ ]
allez vous faire
bonjour madame petite question pendant
le festival de cannes
que pensez vous de tous ces journalistes
qui profitent de ce festival de cannes
pour emmerder les vieux bourgeois
réactive vote à droite et le cochon de
bourgeois réactionnaire fasciste droite
ou feu sous louer
[Musique]
où
excusez moi je suis non voyants savent
où je peux trouver de la drogue
c'est pas moi qui volent au pardon
excusez moi merci insultes excusez moi
monsieur je suis handicapé les voir on
pouvait prendre la cri dans la poche
gauche s'il vous plaît été ma voiture
merci aux voleurs excusez moi mais
toujours pas de mari n'est pas là si
c'est moi que non le monsieur telle ou
telle autre jour des jo excusez moi je
cherche un magasin le clitoris
dégage un jouet pour enfant le plus
torride où vous aviez par l'or n'est pas
là que je t'ai montrer aux usa où je
t'ai montrer ceci pour un dessert de
france
oui je vous fais je sais je suis pas
how jeter montrer oui mais où
voilà excusez moi je n'ai pas vu passer
le bouffeur de cul ou quoi vous faire le
plus
merci
cet après midi faste après midi ont dit
pas un
on dit pas de quoi en amont dit comment
allons enfants de la patrie le jour de
gloire est arrivé
[Applaudissements]
un génie jarry de l'appel figurent et
c'est un génie c'est un jeu que j'adore
ouais c'est vrai qu'il faudrait qu'il le
refasse je te veux ou deux ans je
propose de faire une grosse émission sur
jean yves lafesse et oui mais il faut
vraiment la faire on est d'accord cyril
je pense qu'il faut vraiment l'alluré un
vraiment la soeur vraiment la cei et là
ça va se faire alors la fin alors qu'il
vous a dit non latins le vrai patron
petite suisse appelée francs capitaux à
cette heure-là il au sauna au ladder
note franck vous adore et c'est vrai que
je laime qu'il ait sa part et j'aiderai
de préférence et bus et va te répond on
à toi nord-est
ça va mon chéri d'amour d'ivoire on est
dans l'émotion la grande d'arcade donc
me dis pas que tu vas me bouffer le cul
ou un truc comme ça ça fait mal
je suis avec raphaël mezrahi
il me dit qu'ils voulaient faire une
émission son genre yves lafesse et je
lui dis on va appeler le grand patron le
président pour savoir s'il est pour ou
s'il est contre qu'est ce t'en penses on
a revu des extraits là qu'on passe dans
la grande barca est exceptionnel merci
mon son fait mais on t'embrasse au chili
ge est rappelé et je peux vous dire
quelque chose que j'essaie rien à voir
avec oui bien sûr j'ai toujours eu peur
de demander vous êtes la preuve qu' on
demande
on a fait ce qu'on voulait mais avec
vous la mecque ouais bah oui beeman mec
qui aime bien manger des sacs à main des
rigoles et même faire l'amour tous arme
d'en manger ils aiment faire l'amour
ouais mais il est gay
[Applaudissements]
on gère bien le profil de buman et je
craque sur cannes qu'elle fait plutôt un
mètre soixante dix c'est très bizarre
parviens tu vas la kent
va bien tiffany intéressant parce
qu'elle est elle et sa mère et lui on
lui propose le rend triste mais sur ce
qui semble bien résumer ma vie non c'est
intéressant c'est qu'elle a une coloc
attend colloque
oui j'ai très peur de vivre seul elle
est célibataire
non c'est mon meilleur ami l'avion avec
qui je vis d'obama comme ça mais si ça
faisait baiser par les fantômes s'était
pas les fantômes
[Applaudissements]
duquel sont affrontés j'ai commencé ma
dernière et le mec est braquée vous
aimez pas arrêter de nous prendre pour
des cons
allez les séries ya rafael caro voulu
revoir une caméra cachée de
l'holographie parce que c'est vrai que
l'eau fait partie de nos idoles même
mois il succès large et une manne de
lolo et pendant un micro trottoir sur
les champs elysées lolo est tombé sur
une pépite
il lui a fait croire que patrick
sébastien avait été viré celle là je les
revues peut-être mille fois je ne m'en
lasse pas allez brest 1 selon sébastien
col a fichu dehors parce qu'ils
défendent directeur mais nous il nous
plaît il a une tête sympathique et à une
tête vraiment qu'ils passent très bien
la télévision on voit bien à patrick
hivon regarde chez lui en larmes
probablement à ben j'en parlerais même
pas cette règle
il faut pas pleurer mais je pense pas un
don c'est pas le genre à pleurer
alors monsieur sabatier c'est dacia j'me
tout bascule revenez ramener nos vies et
arrangez vous avec levier la direction
bien manger leur pardon hein d'avoir été
peut-être un peu brute un peu brusque
dans vos propos il a dit il a des
dictats mer oui mais moi je dis bien le
traîne tant qu ancien du luxe à la place
droit ou en bleu l'horreur
pas de guillemets son directeur en avant
par les cellules sur les champs de
course lui un riche homme d'affaires
avec vous annonce qui alors il a rien
rien rien pour lui si tu planes revient
rien moi je n'ai aucun nom moi je les ai
vus dans la rue une étude prétention
mais si vous voulez pas savoir à guy lux
il est prétentieux vu l'énorme harry
n'est pas d'accord non c'est super ce
débat je sais c'est pour mon mari
marie mais c'est pas mon rendez compte
madame ils ont viré pezi janvier
sébastien
d'accord
génial à dallas
elle est
on sait rafale est gentil mais on n'est
plus qu'à me raphaël et moi c'est vrai
on est frères mes frais et ça moi j'ai
rien fait j'ai la chance de tomber sur
mon appel lesman qu'une bonne clients
dans ses hypers leur art elle a fait un
sujet c'était inouï à meetic stock
fabuleuse franchement on a vécu deux ans
donc j'ai à dire elle a dit c'est pas
moi je dis que la monte ton cul vous
hélas tout alors charisme alors elle est
exceptionnelle on partage un rappel à
l'amour des mamies trapel on évite
ivoire morissette et c'est tout a une
manie à charenton-le-pont boucounta
quitter et j'ai amené mon logis bien les
hangars morissette
il a fait signer un chèque de converger
il récent chez qu'équipe renner et je
vais j'ai fait signer un chèque d'un
million d'euros qui va avoir un set
j'avais du bandiat de béthoncourt cadre
il est chez moi chez nous